depuis la mort du facteur cheval c'est
la corde des dizaines de milliers de
touristes qui chaque été se rend à l'est
et al c'est le facteur le plus célèbre
de la drôme pendant 33 ans ferdinand
cheval plus connu sous le nom de facteur
cheval a édifié un gigantesque palais à
auterive un palais classé monument
historique en 1969 conséquence dans les
années 70 les commerces locaux profiter
de ce succès
si le visiteur trouve localement les
cartes postales destinées à la famille
et aux amis
le succès touristique est également
suffisant pour permettre aux parties
fier confiseurs d'auterive
les coulées à tonnage considérable de
cailloux du palais idéal la renommée du
site ne s'arrête pas en france dans les
années 90 elle dépasse même les
frontières
les touristes viennent alors du monde
entier pour contempler le palais nous
sommes des irlandais je viens de
l'allemagne de francfort 2 et non à la
fin des années 2000
près d'un siècle après sa construction
le palais idéal attire toujours autant
les touristes sont au rendez vous au
grand bonheur des employés
l'art brut fait recette à la caisse du
palais du facteur cheval les ventes de
tickets sont à la hausse
[Musique]
contexte de la crise effectivement on
s'attendait pas pour l'instant rex parce
que ça se passe aussi bien en 2018
près de 170 mille visiteurs se sont
pressés pour admirer le palais idéal un
chiffre atteint en huit mois seulement
2010 9 grâce en partie à la sortie d'un
film consacré au facteur cheval
[Musique]